all right guys very very quick video this one...
a warning about scams in the comments of the
videos so um it's been happening for probably the
last few months now people have been um basically
scammers have been replying to comments to the
videos often they use my picture the logo of
the channel as their picture sometimes they
use names which are similar to the name of
the channel like it might be like Gary economic
instead of Gary's economics and they generally say
um please message me on Whatsapp or please
message me on telegram please message me on Signal
just basically to say this is not me um theseare
basically scammers I think we've got some messages
saying they ask people for money so um yeah I
never asked you to contact me on Whatsapp or
Signal if I don't want anyone to message me
I'll probably say to missing my website or
my Twitter or my Instagram which are both Gary's
Economics um I know there's no messaging function
on YouTube but yeah I will never ask you
to message me on on WhatsApp on Signal on
Telegram and I'll definitely not ask you for
money over what type of telegram or signal so
just be careful there are some scammers on the
comments it's not just this channel I think it's
a problem all over YouTube we obviously
do everything we can to delete them if we
see them to report them if we see them but
you know they keep popping up always from
different accounts so yeah be careful um don't
get scammed um and yeah thanks for your support